une tristesse parce que le bâtonnier
solo était toujours très présents aux
barreaux même s'il était à la retraite
ensuite nous avons perdu l'an dernier le
bâtonnier valère perdre cette année le
bâtonnier cholot c'est vraiment le
barreau il essuie des coups durs alors
le bâtonnier cholot je crois que s'il y
a une chose qu'on peut dire parce que ça
a vraiment marqué le barreau c'est qu'il
a été un précurseur en matière de
nouvelles technologies
c'est à titre personnel pour son cabinet
et pour l'ordre c'était quelqu'un qui
était féru de nouvelles technologies et
qui a mené le barreau sur la voie de
cette modernisation est donc nous lui
devons beaucoup pour cela a suscité un
homme de culture comme il a été dit il a
été effectivement président longtemps de
cette structure et c'était un homme qui
était présent à toutes les
manifestations culturelles il était très
curieux de la vie culturelle de son pays
il était très engagé dans tout ce qui
pouvait permettre le développement de
l'homme martiniquais donc c'est ce que
je retiens à la fois en tant que
bâtonnier il était soucieux de l'intérêt
de l'ordre en tant qu'avocat c'était un
bon professionnel en tant que
martiniquais c'était un homme soucieux
du développement de son pays